Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家预告一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up on today's episode of the podcast, I am talking to Dr. Juliette Young about ways that we can be more creative in the work that we do with our clients and service users.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天的播客中，我将与朱丽叶·杨博士（Dr. Juliette Young）探讨如何在与客户和服务对象的工作中发挥更多创造力。
We're also talking about how she got into psychology and what her experiences were like of doing her training during the pandemic. She also offers us her top tips for reducing burnout as an aspiring psychologist. Hope you find this episode so useful. Welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. I love being able to introduce you to the backstories of people you may already have heard of or you may already follow on social media and today's guest might well be one of those people because she does wonderful illustrations all about mental health and working as a psychologist. We are talking to Dr. Juliette Young, also known
我们还将讨论她是如何进入心理学领域的，以及她在疫情期间完成培训的经历。她还为立志成为心理学家的人提供了减少职业倦怠的实用建议。希望这期节目对你有所帮助。欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。我喜欢向大家介绍那些你们可能已经听说过或在社交媒体上关注过的人的背景故事，而今天的嘉宾很可能就是其中之一，因为她创作了许多关于心理健康和心理学家工作的精彩插画。我们采访的是朱丽叶·杨博士，也被称为
as Creative Clinical Psychologist. You will get to learn the backstory of how she ended up in psychology and also one of the other professional psychology disciplines that she considered before becoming a clinical psychologist. Let's dive in and hear all about it and I'll catch you on the other side. Hi, I just want to welcome along Dr. Juliette Young to the podcast, who is a qualified clinical psychologist and also a really creative clinical psychologist too. Hi, Juliette. Hiya. So we first crossed paths because somebody had said they'd love to see us talk to one another and that was over on Twitter forward slash x whatever it is these days. Before we get into you and your fantastically creative illustration ways can we have a little
“创意临床心理学家”（Creative Clinical Psychologist）。你将了解到她是如何走上心理学之路的，以及她在成为临床心理学家之前考虑过的另一个专业心理学学科。让我们深入了解一下，稍后见。嗨，欢迎朱丽叶·杨博士来到播客，她不仅是一位合格的临床心理学家，也是一位非常有创意的临床心理学家。你好，朱丽叶。你好。我们最初的交集是因为有人说很想看到我们交流，那是在推特（现在的X）上。在我们深入探讨你那些极具创意的插画方式之前，我们能先聊聊
bit of a think about you and psychology? Yeah, yeah, sure. So how did you... What would you like to know? Everything. When did you first take an interest in psychology and how did that unfold for you? When I was back in secondary school, actually, I wasn't very well behaved in secondary school and I would often be sent to the head teacher's office or the deputy head's office. And I had been watching Tanya Byron's Little Angels I don't know whether people will remember that or whether aspiring psychologists are old enough to remember that but it was a TV show that a psychologist went in and helped parents to think about their children's behaviour through a kind of needs-based lens so I was I was
你和心理学吗？好的，当然可以。你想知道什么？一切。你是什么时候开始对心理学产生兴趣的，这段经历又是如何展开的？其实是在我上中学的时候，那时我的表现不太好，经常被叫到校长或副校长的办公室。我当时一直在看坦尼娅·拜伦（Tanya Byron）的《小天使》（Little Angels），不知道大家还记不记得，或者现在的心理学准从业者们是否够大能记得那个节目。那是一档电视节目，心理学家走进家庭，通过一种基于需求的角度帮助父母思考孩子的行为，所以我当时
really fascinated by that and interested. And then in school, when I would be sent to the teacher's office, I would kind of bring in this, well, they need to be doing this better. They need to be thinking about this. And the deputy headteacher at the time said to me, Juliet, you should be an educational psychologist. And of course, I didn't know what that meant but that sort of stuck with me so I guess that's that's kind of where it began. I love that they didn't just see you as being precocious and put you back in their box they thought she's kind of good at this we should probably help her cultivate this. Yeah. Nice so then then presumably you went off to university to study psychology
非常着迷。后来在学校，当我被叫到老师办公室时，我会带入这种视角，比如“他们需要做得更好，他们需要思考这个问题”。当时的副校长对我说：“朱丽叶，你应该成为一名教育心理学家。”当然，我当时并不知道那意味着什么，但这句话一直印在我的脑海里，所以我想这就是一切的开始。我喜欢他们没有仅仅把你视为早熟的孩子并把你关回笼子里，而是认为你在这方面很有天赋，应该帮助你培养它。是的。太棒了，那么后来你大概就去大学学习心理学了？
yes so I did a I did a BTEC at college I I didn't do the normal route of of A levels and within that was a kind of a module on psychology and that's where I I fell in love with it and then after a year out um decided that actually I did want to go to university and then yeah applied and got on studied at UWE to do my undergraduate. Great and did you then fall in love with clinical psychology during your undergrad degree or did that come later? No so I had no idea what clinical psychology was probably until I don't know six or seven years ago actually um so that would have been yeah I started that 16 years ago so there's a big chunk where I didn't know what clinical psychology was um and it wasn't until I knew what educational psychology was
是的，我在学院读了BTEC课程，我没有走A-level的常规路线，其中有一个心理学模块，我就是在那时爱上了它。在间隔年之后，我决定去上大学，然后申请并进入了西英格兰大学（UWE）攻读本科。太棒了，那你是在本科期间爱上临床心理学的，还是后来才接触到的？没有，我大概直到六七年前才知道什么是临床心理学。我16年前开始接触心理学，所以中间有很长一段时间我根本不知道临床心理学是什么。直到我知道了什么是教育心理学，
because my teacher had mentioned it and I I got a job after my under working in like an eating disorder, a home for people with eating disorders really. And decided through that that I really did want to pursue a career in educational psychology. So I went and got a job in a school and then worked there for six months, went and got a job in another school, worked there for five years, and within that time applied for educational psychology. And I didn't get on. And actually, within that process, so yes, it was around about the same time as I read a book called, again, by Dr. Tanya Byron, A Skeleton Cupboard. What that book does is it gives, I think it's four case studies and talks about these people and their difficulties
因为我的老师提到过它。本科毕业后，我找到了一份工作，是在一家饮食失调康复中心。通过那份工作，我决定一定要追求教育心理学的职业生涯。于是我找了一份学校的工作，在那里工作了六个月，后来又换到另一所学校工作了五年，期间我申请了教育心理学，但没被录取。其实在那个过程中，大约是在同一时间，我读了坦尼娅·拜伦博士写的《骷髅碗柜》（A Skeleton Cupboard）。那本书提供了四个案例研究，讲述了这些人及其困难，
and really it sort of formulates. And that really captured me and really made me think, actually, maybe I really like this idea of formulation and thinking about people's needs. And yeah, so I then decided that I needed to get a job within the NHS and get some experience in mental health services. So I got a job working on crisis teams they're known as in Bristol and intensive teams they're also called in the broader trust that I work in and just doing bank shifts so yeah so adult mental health services and then also decided I wanted to do a masters to just try and get my head into clinical psychology so I ended up this
并进行了很好的归纳。这深深吸引了我，让我开始思考，也许我真的很喜欢这种归纳和思考人们需求的想法。于是我决定必须在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）内找一份工作，积累心理健康服务的经验。我在布里斯托尔的危机干预小组（Crisis teams）找到了一份工作，在更大的信托机构里也被称为强化小组（Intensive teams），我只是做一些临时轮班。所以，是的，我进入了成人心理健康服务领域，同时也决定攻读硕士学位，试图让自己进入临床心理学的轨道。所以我最终……
there's probably a long there's a bit of a long story behind this but i ended up going to the university of east london um to study clinical and community psychology um now when i applied for this i kind of went on it because i was really captured by community psychology and what the the course outline was um without really realizing that how far east the University of East London is from Bristol and I would get up at four or five in the morning, get on a coach, get to central London, go for a day of lectures and then do the same return journey. So I did that for a year, well not quite a year, I think it was eight months once a week um and then alongside that um and while doing the crisis work also got a job as my first job as an assistant psychologist lovely gosh yeah that is quite the commute isn't it I don't know you only need one
这背后可能有一个很长的故事，但我最终去了东伦敦大学（UEL）攻读临床与社区心理学。申请时，我被社区心理学以及课程大纲所吸引，却没意识到东伦敦大学离布里斯托尔有多远。我每天早上四五点起床，坐长途大巴去伦敦市中心，上一整天课，然后再做同样的往返旅程。我这样坚持了一年，其实不到一年，大概八个月，每周一次。与此同时，在做危机干预工作的同时，我还得到了第一份助理心理学家的工作。太棒了，天哪，那通勤真的很辛苦，不是吗？你只需要一次
decent train strike or delay and it just sends your whole day into chaos yeah I think there was a time when I think it was the Beast from the East, I don't know whether you remember that, when there was that huge few days of snow and I ended up getting on a coach and going to London for all the lectures to be cancelled and then being stuck in London, having to stay at a friend's house.
像样的火车罢工或延误，整天就会陷入混乱。是的，记得有一次，好像是“东方野兽”（Beast from the East）暴风雪，不知道你还记不记得，当时有几天大雪，我坐大巴去伦敦，结果所有课程都取消了，我被困在伦敦，不得不住在朋友家里。
Oh gosh. But I think what you're really nicely portraying is that actually as an aspiring psychologist we can really spread ourselves very thinly um you know expecting ourselves to be in several places at the same time and you know trying to learn whilst also probably being quite stressed and pressured um and holding many different yeah thoughts in our head and responsibilities you know it's not easy stuff is it no and I think I think you've got to want it and I think you've got to I guess it's about there's there's a a lot of hard work that goes into building that portfolio is it I guess of experiences and but I also think there's there's something about values and for me like going and doing
天哪。但我认为你很好地展现了这一点：作为一名心理学准从业者，我们真的会把自己逼得太紧，期望自己同时出现在好几个地方，在感到压力和紧张的同时还要努力学习，脑子里装着各种想法和责任。这真的不容易，对吧？是的，我认为你必须有强烈的愿望，而且我认为这关乎建立作品集所需的艰苦努力。但我认为这还关乎价值观，对我来说，去读
the masters in UEL like that was I was so inspired by the lectures especially the ones around community psychology and we had a term of doing critical psychology as well that I it didn't feel exhausting or hard if I felt very energized by it I felt very inspired and I felt very I guess it really confirmed to me that I wanted to work in clinical psychology because I could do those things that I kind of saw as educational psychology like working with a wider system thinking in a kind of more systemic way but also yeah but also meeting those needs of kind of wanting to be able to do therapy and I guess it's working across those systems like Bronf and Brenner's ecological systems theory I'm going off on a tangent but yes it's really hard, it's really hard
UEL的硕士课程，我受到了讲座的极大启发，尤其是关于社区心理学的内容，我们还有一个学期学习批判心理学，所以我并不觉得疲惫或困难，反而感到非常有活力和启发。这确实向我证实了我想从事临床心理学，因为我可以做那些我视为教育心理学的事情，比如与更广泛的系统合作，以更系统的方式思考，同时也满足了我想做治疗的需求。我想这就像布朗芬布伦纳（Bronfenbrenner）的生态系统理论一样，我扯远了，但确实，这真的很难，真的很难。
I think and yeah I was I think I was very fortunate to have had quite a lot of experience behind me at the point I decided I wanted to go into that so that kind of acted as a bit of a platform to get my job as an assistant psychologist and to you know get onto the master's course and to be able to be working in a kind of a flexible job doing crisis work to enable me to fund my master's and and to be able to fund you know my rent and stuff like that as well so it's yeah it's it's tough yeah you know um one of the themes in the clinical psychologist collective book was this perseverance um and that you really need it because otherwise at any point you could be like know um one of the themes in the clinical psychologist collective book was this perseverance and that you really need it because otherwise at any point you could be like oh i'm just gonna not
我想，我很幸运在决定进入这个领域时已经有了相当多的经验，这成为了我获得助理心理学家工作、进入硕士课程的平台，也让我能够通过灵活的危机干预工作来资助我的硕士学业、房租等等。所以，这确实很艰难。是的，你知道，《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）一书中的主题之一就是“坚持”，你真的需要它，否则在任何时候你都可能想……
bother i'm gonna go and do something else whereas you know the more and more you persevere the more and more likely you are to actually get to where you need to be to get on the doctorate to get qualified it's it's a lot um you know it is a lot and I remember as I was listening to you speak it was reminding me of when I was doing my master's and I was working full-time while studying a master's part-time whilst I'd also had a car accident I had back problems I'd just broken up with a partner as well there was like there could not have been any more going on in my life and yet it was that year that I did my successful form to get on to the doctorate you know it's like someone might have said to me at any point oh why don't you just
放弃，去做别的事情。而你坚持得越久，就越有可能真正到达你需要去的地方，进入博士课程并获得资格。这真的很多，你知道，这确实很多。我听你说话时，想起了我读硕士的时候，我一边全职工作，一边兼职读硕士，当时我还出了车祸，背部有问题，刚和伴侣分手，生活中不可能有更多的事情发生了。然而，正是在那一年，我成功提交了申请博士的表格。你知道，有人可能在任何时候对我说：“哦，为什么不……”
not apply this year there was would never have been a question but I wasn't going to apply that year you know anytime I wasn't osteo or physio or all crying about my I was working on my form like there was there was never a chance I wasn't going to do it and actually I did get on that year and it the back's fine now the back was fine by the time I started training but it's that that continual motion isn't it you have to you have to want it you know and I guess the support systems around you have to be good enough that you don't burn out yeah and I think that I think you have to want it and I think it's also okay to take a break from it I didn't I was very driven but I had also had sort of taken a break from it and I'd had that you know I'd had several years where I just enjoyed
今年不申请呢？但我从来没想过不申请。即使我当时在做理疗或因为背痛哭泣，我依然在写申请表。我从未想过放弃。事实上，我那年确实被录取了。现在背部已经好了，开始培训时背部也好了。但这就是那种持续的动力，不是吗？你必须想要它。而且我认为你周围的支持系统必须足够好，这样你才不会精疲力竭。是的，我认为你必须想要它，但我也认为休息一下也没关系。我当时很有动力，但也确实休息过，我有几年时间只是享受
working and enjoyed my job working in a school and I wasn't really thinking I was you know I had it in my head what that I wanted to be educational psychologist, but I also really focused on just enjoying my job and growing myself within that. So I guess it's about maintaining that drive, but also there's not a time pressure. I think a lot of aspiring psychologists I've spoken to feel like there's this real urgency to get on. And I completely understand it because if you want something, you want it to be, you know, happening. And if there's a risk, it might not happen. You really, you know, you want, there's that uncertainty and sitting with that uncertainty. But what I always say is that actually that time before training was probably some of the best part of my career so far in that I you know I had
工作，享受在学校的工作，并没有过多考虑。我心里确实想成为教育心理学家，但我同时也专注于享受工作并在其中成长。所以我想这关乎保持动力，但也没有时间压力。我觉得我交谈过的许多心理学准从业者都觉得有一种迫切感。我完全理解，因为如果你想要什么，你希望它尽快发生。如果存在风险，它可能不会发生，你会有那种不确定性，并要学会与这种不确定性共处。但我总是说，培训前的那段时间可能是我职业生涯中最好的部分之一，因为我有
a lot more freedom before you know there's once you're qualified there's a lot more responsibilities and a lot more you know things that you have to do that actually when you're an assistant or when I was working in in the job in the school that yeah you have this sort of freedom and and yeah I would always say to people like training is just one part of your journey. And like, you've got your entire, you know, working life. And to really think about that, actually, it's okay, just to enjoy what you're doing. And obviously, there's financial implications, like, it's really difficult to be, yeah, and that's, that's, it's probably even more so at the moment with the cost of living crisis. But it's really difficult to be on a very low paid job.
更多的自由。你知道，一旦你获得了资格，责任就更多了，必须做的事情也更多了。而当你是一名助理，或者像我当时在学校工作时，你确实拥有那种自由。我总是告诉人们，培训只是你旅程的一部分。你还有整个职业生涯。要真正考虑到这一点，其实，享受你正在做的事情是可以的。当然，这有经济影响，在当前生活成本危机下，这确实非常困难。但从事一份低薪工作真的很艰难。
And I was for, you know, when I worked in the school and assistant psychologists don't get paid amazingly. And like, yeah, I think I think so. I'm saying that by also, I guess, recognising that there is a financial pressure on people to be able to qualify. And I think, yeah, I think that's that's really difficult isn't it and and other people will have um yeah more difficult financial situations and other factors which put pressure on that like having children and yeah absolutely and thank you for that um really nice compassionate reframe because you're right there is no sometimes people say to me oh you know i really need to be qualified by the time i'm 30 and it's like oh why you know you could still you know live your life whilst you're training if you if you want to you
我当时在学校工作时就是这样，助理心理学家的薪水并不高。所以，我是在承认人们为了获得资格确实面临经济压力的前提下说这些的。我认为这真的很难，不是吗？其他人会有更困难的经济状况和其他因素，比如抚养孩子等，这都会增加压力。是的，绝对是这样。谢谢你提供这个非常好的、富有同情心的重新框架，因为你是对的，有时人们对我说：“哦，我真的需要在30岁之前获得资格。”我就想：“哦，为什么？”你完全可以在培训的同时享受生活，如果你愿意的话，
know you can have a family whilst you're on the course if you want to um you can you can flex it to look how you want it to look and when I graduated from my undergrad I went around the world traveling for six months and had I not had those experiences and the experiences of saving up to go traveling and then the experiences of having an absolute ball with my friends and assistant psychologist I love it when the Facebook memories come up of that time you know that all helped with my resilience and with my you know not burning out and with just having fun along the way so that it wasn't just about psychology. You absolutely need more in the background, don't you? Yeah. Yeah. You have to, you know, your life comes first.
你可以在课程期间组建家庭，你可以灵活安排生活。我本科毕业后去环游世界了六个月，如果我没有那些经历，没有攒钱去旅行的经历，没有和朋友们一起度过美好时光的经历，我就不会有现在的韧性，不会在助理心理学家期间避免精疲力竭，也不会在这一路上享受乐趣。所以，这不仅仅是关于心理学。你绝对需要在背景中有更多东西，不是吗？是的。是的。你必须明白，你的生活是第一位的。
Psychology doesn't come first. And yes, we do. You know, we live in a society which means that our communities don't tend to hold us so we do have to get a job and we do have to be able to fund our lifestyle most of the time or most people tend to need that and and um but your life you know you've got to prioritize that because yeah it's really important isn't it is who you are it's what gives you your nourishment and yeah I think that that is yeah or one part of what gives you your nourishment. Yeah I totally agree so what year did you start training as a clinical psychologist then? So I started 2019 so started four years ago been qualified a year. Amazing and how has that journey been for you transitioning from trainee to qualified? I think it's been yeah I think it's been generally a good one I think that training was very challenging because we trained the pandemic hit six months into training and and
心理学不是第一位的。是的，我们生活在一个社区往往无法支撑我们的社会中，所以我们确实必须找工作，必须能够资助我们的生活方式，大多数人确实需要这样。但是，你的生活，你必须优先考虑它，因为它真的很重要，不是吗？它是你是谁，它为你提供滋养，或者说它是为你提供滋养的一部分。是的，我完全同意。那么你是什么时候开始临床心理学培训的？我是2019年开始的，四年前，获得资格一年了。太棒了，从实习生到获得资格，这段旅程对你来说怎么样？我觉得总体来说很好。我认为培训非常有挑战性，因为我们培训六个月后疫情就爆发了，
there were lots of challenges that came with that in terms of placements I mean it gave us more time to be at home because we didn't have to travel to lectures because lectures are online but lots of challenges that came with that in terms of placements. I mean, it gave us more time to be at home because we didn't have to travel to lectures because lectures are online. But I wonder the impact of that on how much information I retained from lectures, just sat staring at a screen. And yeah, my placements were tricky because a lot of them were remote. I don't work very well remotely I like being somewhere like being among people that's kind of how I work best um so I would say that I probably haven't got a comparative experience other than people who trained at
这在实习方面带来了很多挑战。我的意思是，它让我们有更多时间待在家里，因为我们不必去参加讲座，讲座都是在线的。但这也带来了很多挑战。我的意思是，它让我们有更多时间待在家里，因为我们不必去参加讲座，讲座都是在线的。但我怀疑这对我从讲座中吸收了多少信息有影响，毕竟只是盯着屏幕看。而且，我的实习很棘手，因为很多都是远程的。我不擅长远程工作，我喜欢身处某个地方，喜欢和人在一起，那是我工作最好的方式。所以我想我可能没有其他在疫情期间或类似时间培训的人那样的对比经验，
you know the similar time or through the pandemic um but I really enjoyed qualifying and being able to just be in the office more and to go into a job that I loved. And not that I didn't enjoy some of my placements, but there were some, you know, there were some real highlights in some of my placements. But ultimately, where I'm working now is the area that I want to be in. And therefore, it's very values based and it meets that need to you know to be working with my values and with my interests and I think so yeah so I think an easy transition I would say I was definitely ready to qualify I was definitely ready to you know to get out into the world and you know that's not to say that I wasn't training wasn't really important there's lots of gaps that I probably still need to fill and and learning is an ongoing journey
但我真的很享受获得资格，能够更多地待在办公室，去从事我热爱的工作。并不是说我不喜欢我的实习，有些实习确实有真正的亮点。但最终，我现在工作的地方是我想要待的领域。因此，它是非常基于价值观的，满足了我将价值观与兴趣结合的需求。所以，我认为这是一个轻松的过渡。我绝对准备好获得资格了，我绝对准备好进入这个世界了。这并不是说培训不重要，我可能还有很多空白需要填补，学习是一个持续的旅程，
isn't it so I don't mean it in the way that oh yeah you know I just knew everything and I needed to leave but in that I was ready to go and start the next stage yeah yeah and I guess as I hear you talk I guess I'm wondering if there's a niche in the market for doing some research into whether the pandemic cohorts have actually had a more autonomous experience, that it's felt, I don't know, somehow less protected or that you're kind of having to just do more self-directed stuff and having to really force yourself to concentrate and focus. As we know happens when we're trying to Zoom learn, you know, there's always other things going on. Whereas if, like you said, if you're in the room, if you've got your cohort there, you kind of, you have to show up.
不是吗？所以我不是说我什么都知道，不需要再学习了，而是说我已经准备好开始下一个阶段了。是的，听你这么说，我在想，是否有一个市场利基可以研究疫情期间的学员是否实际上有了更自主的体验？感觉好像没那么受保护，或者你不得不做更多自我导向的事情，不得不强迫自己集中注意力。正如我们所知，当我们尝试通过Zoom学习时，总会有其他事情发生。而如果你像你所说的那样，如果你在房间里，如果你有你的同伴在那里，你必须出席。
You have to be concentrating as much as you can. Yeah. And I think that, yeah, it'd be really interesting for someone to look into that. And I also think that there's room for one thing that I think clinical psychology doesn't have is kind of like a yearly refresher or like a two yearly refresher where you have to go back and do some of those things and think about those skills and gaps or I don't know. And I guess that might not work if you're in a very specialist area. But having the opportunity to be able to refresh, I think, would mop up some of those gaps, which, yeah, I think during the pandemic was it was just really hard to learn and to stay engaged.
你必须尽可能集中注意力。是的。我认为有人去研究一下会非常有趣。而且我还认为，临床心理学缺少的一点是某种年度复习或两年一次的复习，让你回去重温那些技能和填补空白。我不知道。如果是在非常专业的领域，这可能行不通。但有机会进行复习，我认为会填补一些空白。在疫情期间，学习和保持参与真的很难。
And you're not having that contact with others other than on the WhatsApp group. And, you know, I was lucky enough to have a very good friend who lives on the roads next to me but other than that there's not that contact time um and I think that's that's a really vital part of training actually is learning from your peers and I feel like I missed out on a lot of that it really is but I think also the training is as much about instilling your confidence in yourself as it is teaching you the stuff. So I remember I was actually unwell for the half a day on the training for how to work with people with a bipolar presentation. Half a day for that. That ended up being kind of quite a key part of my qualified life is working with people within that disorder and I still sometimes wonder like would I be better at this if I'd had that half
你除了在WhatsApp群组里，没有和其他人的接触。我很幸运，有一个住在我家附近的好朋友，但除此之外就没有接触时间了。我认为那是培训中非常重要的一部分，即向同伴学习，我觉得我错过了很多。确实如此，但我认为培训既是关于教你知识，也是关于建立你的自信。我记得我在学习如何与双相情感障碍患者工作的那半天培训时生病了。只有半天。那最终成了我获得资格后生活中相当关键的一部分，即与患有该障碍的人一起工作。我有时还会想，如果我参加了那半天的培训，我会不会做得更好？当然我们知道答案是否定的，因为你怎能指望在半天内学会一整套与人工作、理解和概念化困难的方法呢？你根本做不到。
a day training and of course we know the answer is no because what can you possibly hope to learn about a whole kind of way of working with people and understanding and conceptualizing difficulties in half a day you you just can't, you know? I think that's really true. And actually, you know, what's the saying? Jack of all trades, master of none, that you come out of training with these tiny pockets of things. So, yeah, it probably actually is that there is,
我认为这确实是真的。而且，那句谚语怎么说来着？“样样通，样样松”（Jack of all trades, master of none）。你从培训中出来时，只带着这些微小的知识碎片。所以，是的，可能确实是这样，
I wouldn't have retained all of that stuff, whether I was doing it online or not but I definitely think yeah I identified with that as well I missed um the ACT training for our CAMHS so CAMHS um or acceptance and commitment therapy for CAMHS um and then also for the adult um and I missed both of them I had I was ill for one I had a funeral for the other and I like I just didn't have time to catch up on the lecture notes I think I probably had a look at them but it's not the same as being in a lecture and all the time now because ACT is something that I think I'm really I really identify with with values and thinking you know in the the work I'm doing around
无论我是否在线学习，我都不可能记住所有这些东西。但我绝对认为我也有同感，我错过了CAMHS（儿童和青少年心理健康服务）的ACT（接纳承诺疗法）培训，还有成人的ACT培训。我两个都错过了，一个是因为生病，一个是因为参加葬礼。我根本没有时间补上讲座笔记。我想我可能看了一眼，但这和参加讲座是不一样的。现在，因为ACT是我非常认同价值观的东西，在我的工作中，
um with young people with their asylum claim there's you know as we're going along there's not much we can do about the process which is a very long process so it's helping them think about um you know accepting the situation they're in and what can they do within that to I guess find pockets of happiness through meeting their values whatever so I have a kind of loose idea of what act is but I don't feel like I fully understand it I feel like that's a big gap that I need to, yeah, I need to go and revise and I'd miss during training. I'd say there's always time.
与寻求庇护的年轻人一起工作，我们能做的关于这个过程的事情不多，这是一个非常漫长的过程。所以，这是帮助他们思考如何接纳他们所处的境地，以及在其中他们能做些什么来找到快乐的片段，无论是什么。所以我对ACT有一个模糊的概念，但我觉得我没有完全理解它。我觉得这是一个我需要去复习的大空白，我在培训期间错过了。我想总会有时间的。
And, you know, even now I'm experiencing and, you know, enjoying learning about new topics and new areas. I love an audio book. And so that's a really nice way for me to learn things. You know, you are fairly newly qualified and you can just give yourself time to bed into being qualified and just, yeah, turn to more, you know, learning and enhancing your learning needs as and when the time is ready, I would say. So you've told us really nicely a little bit about some of the qualified work you do there. I think you work a split post, am I right in saying? Yeah, yeah. So in teams that are sort of attached to each other.
即使是现在，我也在体验和享受学习新主题和新领域的过程。我喜欢有声读物，这是我学习东西的一种很好的方式。你刚获得资格不久，你可以给自己时间去适应，并在准备好时，转向更多的学习和提升你的学习需求。那么，你刚才很好地向我们介绍了一些你所做的合格工作。我想你是做分职工作，对吗？是的，在彼此相关的团队中。
But yeah, two different distinct roles, both clinical psychology roles. Brilliant. Are you happy to say a little bit more? You don't have to identify the service you work in or anything, but are you happy to say a little bit more you don't have to identify the service you work in or anything but are you happy to say a little bit more yeah yeah yeah yeah so I work so two days a week I work in um a service for children in foster care um and that is mainly working with the systems around young people although I have got a few young people that I see weekly for therapy sessions um and that's where I worked as an assistant psychologist as well so it was sort of like coming home um and I really love that work I really like the complexity I like working with systems I like thinking about attachment and trauma I'm really interested in
但确实是两个不同的角色，都是临床心理学角色。太棒了。你愿意多说一点吗？你不必透露你工作的服务机构或任何东西，但你愿意多说一点吗？是的，我每周有两天在寄养儿童服务机构工作，这主要是与年轻人周围的系统合作，尽管我也有几个年轻人每周进行治疗。那也是我担任助理心理学家时工作的地方，所以感觉就像回家一样。我真的很喜欢那份工作，我喜欢复杂性，喜欢与系统合作，喜欢思考依恋和创伤。我对
in kind of developmental trauma and the impact of that and how I guess how that can be some of that can be repaired um so that's the two days a week and then two and a half days a week um I work a nine day fortnight um two and a half days a week is in the asylum seeker and refugee clinic um and that is working with children seeking asylum families as well um and um it's primarily a trauma service so we've got quite a narrow commissioning in that it is it is just you know working around post-traumatic stress and um yeah but that is prevalent in in that population because most people who have had to leave their country of origin have experienced you know horrific trauma, either when they were there or on their journey. So, yeah, so a lot of our children, a lot of our referrals meet our criteria anyway.
发展性创伤及其影响非常感兴趣，以及如何修复其中的一些创伤。所以这是每周两天。然后每周两天半，我实行九天两周制，在寻求庇护者和难民诊所工作。那是与寻求庇护的儿童及其家庭一起工作。它主要是一个创伤服务机构，我们的委托范围相当狭窄，就是围绕创伤后应激障碍工作。但这在这一人群中很普遍，因为大多数不得不离开原籍国的人都经历过可怕的创伤，无论是在那里还是在旅途中。所以，我们的很多孩子，很多转诊都符合我们的标准。
I once did a very specialist piece of work linked to a GP who specialised in supporting asylum seekers and refugees. And it was just, oh, I just, I learned so much about being human and humble and really, I guess, really, like you said, boiling down those core values of what's important to me, what's important to them, and how we can kind of try and help people find some sort of stability in a world that feels like it's just swirling and ever-changing really tricky stuff yeah I think that's that's a really it's really yeah it's I think that's really kind of hit that hit the nail on the head in the in the kind of the swirling got an image in my mind of this yeah the kind of swirling stuff around them and I as an example I did an assessment last week and I drew out Bronfenbrenner's
我曾经做过一项非常专业的工作，与一位专门支持寻求庇护者和难民的全科医生合作。我学到了很多关于人性、谦逊的知识，真的，就像你说的，提炼出那些对我、对他们来说重要的核心价值观，以及我们如何帮助人们在那个感觉像是不断旋转和变化的世界中找到某种稳定感。这真的很棘手。是的，我认为这真的……我想这真的击中了要害，那种旋转的感觉。我脑海中有一个画面，那些围绕着他们的旋转的东西。举个例子，我上周做了一个评估，我画出了布朗芬布伦纳的
ecological systems theory and kind of talked about as a way of validating like I know all of this stuff is you know going on in on your in your country of origin and the impact of seeing that on social media I know that your your asylum claim is really causing you lots of stress. I know that things within the system around you is really stressful. And unfortunately, I might be able to write a letter to the solicitor to give them a nudge to give you some more information. I might be able to do some drawings to try and make a shift in the wider system, even if it's a very minute mute shift but ultimately the we're restricted to working you know with you and and with with just within the individual and and i
生态系统理论，并以此作为一种验证方式，比如：“我知道所有这些事情正在你的原籍国发生，在社交媒体上看到这些的影响，我知道你的庇护申请确实让你压力很大。我知道你周围系统中的事情确实非常令人紧张。”不幸的是，我或许能给律师写封信，提醒他们提供更多信息。我或许能画些图，试图在更广泛的系统中做出改变，即使是非常微小的改变。但最终，我们被限制在与你个人一起工作，我……
think that's yeah i think it's really hard for people to to get and understandably so because actually if your mental health and well-being is being impacted or the main the main difficulty um for you are these other things going on in your life and somebody is sitting down in a room with you to do therapy and you're like well that's that's not what I need I need that other stuff to change and and so it's I think it's yeah it's an interesting job to be in because actually a lot of the time you're working within systems which are making people more unhappy, more stressed. They're exacerbating some of their symptoms. Like it's a real challenge to do that. And sometimes I really question when people are like, this isn't going to be, why would would doing some you know breathing exercises and and um you know muscle relaxation that's not going to change the fact
我认为这真的很难让人们理解，这是可以理解的。因为如果你的心理健康和幸福受到影响，或者你的主要困难是生活中发生的这些其他事情，而有人坐在房间里和你做治疗，你会想：“好吧，那不是我需要的，我需要改变的是其他事情。”所以，我认为这是一份有趣的工作，因为很多时候你是在让人们变得更不快乐、压力更大的系统中工作。它们加剧了他们的一些症状。这确实是一个挑战。有时我真的很质疑，当人们说……这不会……为什么做一些呼吸练习和肌肉放松就能改变我面临庇护申请的事实？这可能会把我送回一个我会被杀害的国家。你必须非常小心，确保你在提供服务的同时进行验证。
that I've got an asylum claim hanging over me which might send me back to a country where I'm killed and and it's sort of you know you it's it's very it's very you've got to be very careful I think to make sure that you're validating alongside what you're offering. Yeah validation was absolutely the word that I was thinking of but also just extending some compassion and sometimes just being seen for where you're at right now and having a space to kind of explore how that feels can be wonderfully transformative. Yeah I think relationships and if I sort of look through the lenses the attachment lenses that in my other role and apply them within the role with asylum seeking children is thinking about actually safe relationships and you know I think
是的，验证绝对是我在想的词，但也只是表达一些同情，有时只是被看到你现在的处境，并有一个空间来探索这种感觉，这可能是非常具有变革性的。是的，我认为关系，如果我通过依恋视角来看待，并在我与寻求庇护儿童的角色中应用它们，那就是思考安全的关系。我认为
it's the trauma recovery model that actually the bottom of it is safe relationships therapeutic relationships and I think that yeah if I can offer that space even if we don't do the trauma work that we're we're kind of there to do it's giving somebody an experience of somebody who is safe and containing and listening and in a world that's very hostile you know yeah just the the context which is very hostile if you're a young asylum seeker especially if you're unaccompanied arriving in the UK then that is you know that's somebody who's giving something that is the opposite to hostile and and I guess somewhere along the line will will give you a sense of safety in the world even if it's a very small one. Absolutely and I find myself kind of drawing comparisons between foster care systems so when I work with people in the asylum seeking role people
这是创伤恢复模型，其基础是安全的关系、治疗性的关系。我认为，如果我能提供那个空间，即使我们不做我们本该做的创伤工作，这也是给某人一种体验，即有一个安全、包容和倾听的人。在一个非常敌对的世界里，你知道，如果是一个年轻的寻求庇护者，特别是如果你是独自抵达英国的，那么这就是有人在给予与敌对相反的东西。我想在某个时候，这会给你一种世界上的安全感，即使是非常微小的安全感。绝对是这样。我发现自己会将寄养系统与我在寻求庇护者角色中工作时进行比较。人们
contacted me kind of years later to say you know thanks and actually that made a real difference and just being able to hear your voice at times that felt really challenging and being able to draw upon some of the stuff we'd done actually really did make a difference and it's knowing that you can kind of you can still check back in you know if if they want to. So we don't kind of lead that ourselves. But I don't know, maybe years down the line, people will come back to you and say, gosh, that was really incredibly powerful. And I think that's a really nice thing
多年后联系我，说：“谢谢，那真的产生了影响。”能够听到你的声音，在那些感觉非常具有挑战性的时刻，能够借鉴我们做过的一些事情，真的产生了影响。知道你可以随时回来咨询，如果他们愿意的话。我们不会主动引导，但谁知道呢，也许多年以后，人们会回来对你说：“天哪，那真的非常有力量。”我认为这是一件非常美好的事情，
that you get to be part of someone else's story, even though you may never know that you're still being held in mind. It's a real magical thing we do, I yeah so it's a it's a real privilege I think isn't it um to be in that position um and yeah to be able to have that sort of impact on people's lives and to be with them and and a lot of the trauma work I do, like it's such an honour for people to share their story with me. Like it really is like an amazing honour to hear and witness, you know, their story and some of the really awful things that they've never shared with anyone since they've arrived in the UK. Other than maybe on their, you know, in a very formal way in their in their application but in you know thinking about the
你能够成为别人故事的一部分，即使你可能永远不知道你仍然被记在心里。我们所做的是一件真正神奇的事情。是的，我认为这是一种真正的特权，不是吗？能够处于那个位置，能够对人们的生活产生那种影响，并与他们在一起。我做的很多创伤工作，人们与我分享他们的故事，这对我来说是一种荣誉。这真的是一种惊人的荣誉，去倾听和见证他们的故事，以及一些他们自抵达英国以来从未与任何人分享过的、非常可怕的事情。除了可能在他们的申请中以非常正式的方式提到过，但在思考……
emotional impact thinking about yeah but I guess being alongside them in an emotional way in in sharing that is like a deep privilege like it really is like yeah I'm very lucky to have that really yeah and that the ability to be able to kind of help them de-shame that process as well is, you know, amazing. So important. So tell us a little bit then about your wonderful illustrations and how you started to weave that into your clinical work with people? Well, I guess, I mean, I have always drawn and illustrated, you know, my whole life, really. So it's and so it's sort of a natural, a natural thing to bring it into my work. And when, you know, when I worked in the school, I would be doing sessions with young people and I would be drawing to try and help, you know, think about ideas.
情感上的影响，想到这些，是的，但我认为能以一种情感的方式陪伴他们，分享这些经历，这是一种深刻的荣幸，真的，是的，我很幸运能拥有这些。而且能够帮助他们消除对这一过程的羞耻感，你知道，这太棒了。非常重要。那么，给我们讲讲你那些精彩的插画，以及你是如何开始将它们融入到你的临床工作中的？嗯，我想，我的意思是，我一直都在画画和创作插画，你知道，我的一生都是这样。所以，将它带入我的工作中是一种很自然的事情。当我在学校工作时，我会和年轻人进行交流，我会通过画画来尝试帮助他们思考一些想法。
And it often takes the focus off that kind of dyad doesn't it it it takes a different focal point and enables conversation so I think I'll probably bring it into my clinical or have been bringing it into my clinical work for a long time I guess that when it kind of ended up getting like publicly coming into view. Is that what you mean? Like, how does it kind of evolve? Or do you mean? Yeah. So I guess I mean, I just bought a tablet in the pandemic about I think it's about three years ago and thought I would share some drawings on various concepts. And and yeah, just gave it a go and and yeah it just became really popular and it still sort of surprises me now that everyone likes my drawings so much and and
这通常会转移那种二元关系的焦点，不是吗？它提供了一个不同的关注点，并促进了对话。所以我认为我可能会把它带入我的临床工作，或者说我已经把它带入我的临床工作很长一段时间了，我想当它最终公开出现在人们视野中时。你是这个意思吗？你是说它是如何演变的？还是说？是的。所以我想我的意思是，我在疫情期间买了一个平板电脑，大概是三年前吧，我想分享一些关于各种概念的画作。然后，是的，只是尝试了一下，然后它就变得非常受欢迎，直到现在，大家如此喜欢我的画作仍然让我感到惊讶，而且
I think I put one yesterday that was about um compassionate leadership and it's you know sort of a thousand people have liked it and there's lots of shares and lots of comments in it and and I think that it yeah the feedback i've had is that people find it really useful to use in their clinical work to to kind of distill ideas down into a visual concept and and that that can be really useful you know because there's lots of really complex concepts in psychology aren't there and and we live in an increasingly visual world so yeah so that's that's kind of what I hope to do that's sort of what's ended up happening and it's ended up you know I do various other there's been various offshoots from it now which I really enjoy so I did see the one
我想我昨天发了一张关于同理心领导力的画，你知道，大概有一千人点赞，有很多转发和评论。我认为反馈是人们觉得它在临床工作中非常有用，可以将想法提炼成视觉概念，这真的很有用，因为心理学中有很多非常复杂的概念，不是吗？而且我们生活在一个日益视觉化的世界里，所以是的，这就是我希望做的事情，这就是最终发生的事情，它最终导致了，你知道，我现在还有各种其他的衍生作品，我真的很喜欢。所以我确实看到了那一张
you mentioned I think it was like it was almost like a waterfall like was that like a rainbowy waterfall it was really really nice really nice and I'm just in awe of you because um I just I'm just not very good at art I have these wonderful ideas in my head and then that doesn't come out of my pen like it doesn't it doesn't it doesn't translate but you do yours on a tablet do you so is that how that like are you like an apple pen kind of girl how does it work practically I don't I don't have a I don't have an iPad I've got Samsung people I always get messages saying what do you what do you do these on and people often think that it's on an app actually and there's like a clip art image and I'm just bringing them together but
你提到的那一张，我想就像瀑布一样，那是彩虹色的瀑布吗？真的很棒，非常好。我真的很佩服你，因为我不太擅长艺术。我的脑子里有这些美妙的想法，但它们却无法从我的笔下呈现出来，无法转化。但你是在平板电脑上画的，对吧？所以它是怎么运作的？你是那种用苹果笔的人吗？实际操作是怎么样的？我没有iPad，我有三星。人们总是发信息问我用什么画的，人们通常认为那是一个应用程序，里面有剪贴画，我只是把它们拼在一起，但
it's all hand-drawn so I yeah so I just I've got a an app called Ibis which is I don't think it's like a well-known one at all but it's just what I started using and now I'm most familiar with and yeah I'll just draw them and and it can take sometimes they can be very quick sometimes it can take me hours and hours and hours and I really enjoy you know I really enjoy doing it it's very therapeutic for me to sit down and draw and just have the creativity or the time to be able to be creative, actually the freedom to be able to kind of create. And I think in pictures. So I often, you know, I think in like I see concepts and I kind of I'm visualizing all the time things. So it's it's just kind of kind of yeah putting that that then gets translate translated into yeah drawing it and sometimes they're not that good either people sort of say
它们都是手绘的。所以我有一个叫Ibis的应用程序，我不认为它是一个很有名的软件，但这只是我开始使用的，现在我最熟悉它。是的，我会画出来，有时很快，有时可能需要花费我数小时的时间。我真的很享受，我真的很享受创作的过程。对我来说，坐下来画画，拥有创造力或者有时间去创造，实际上拥有创造的自由，是非常治愈的。而且我是用图像来思考的。所以我经常，你知道，我思考时就像我看到了概念，我一直在脑海中构思事物。所以这只是，是的，把这些转化为绘画。有时它们也不是那么好，人们会说
oh like I quite like your scruffy little drawings like I just think that sometimes there's like a wonky arm and it like kind of it doesn't all come together but and there's some that I've done which I sort of look at and just think that's awful um But yeah, there's there's yeah, that's just sort of how how it comes together, really. I like that. I think life is imperfect, isn't it? And sometimes it doesn't need to be pristine and polished. And I'm sure it's still even your scruffy ones that you don't like are still far above what I get to achieve. How did you start to think about putting putting your ideas down into a book how did that come about? So I was contacted actually by an
哦，我挺喜欢你那些潦草的小画的。我只是觉得有时画里有歪歪扭扭的手臂，它并没有完全融合在一起。但我做过一些画，我看着它们，只觉得太糟糕了。但是的，这就是它呈现出来的方式。我喜欢这样。我认为生活是不完美的，不是吗？有时它不需要完美无瑕、精雕细琢。我相信即使是你那些你不喜欢的潦草画作，也远超我所能达到的水平。你是怎么开始考虑把你的想法写成书的？那是怎么发生的？所以我实际上被一位
editor from Jessica Kingsley Publishers and she just contacted me saying I really like your drawings I like how you sort of distill concepts down and your explanations as well like would you be interested in in doing a book in like maybe kind of a I think she suggested maybe a clinical psychology one or CBT or sort of an area and I like you know I was honoured when she emailed me that because I just thought that's you know what a privilege for somebody to be thinking about um you know offering you that opportunity and yeah and then that that formed into I actually contacted two of my lecturers because I thought if I'm going to do a an illustrated guide to clinical psychology lecturers who teach on courses about clinical psychology are the best place to go. And I contacted one who's very, not very actually, that's probably unfair, but she's a CBT, she's a qualified CBT therapist.
来自Jessica Kingsley出版社的编辑联系了。她联系我说，我真的很喜欢你的画，我喜欢你提炼概念的方式，还有你的解释。你是否有兴趣写一本书，比如她建议可能是一本关于临床心理学、CBT或者某个领域的书。我当时感到很荣幸，因为我只是觉得，有人能想到提供给你这样的机会，这是一种荣幸。然后这形成了一个想法，我实际上联系了我的两位讲师，因为我想如果我要写一本临床心理学插图指南，那么在临床心理学课程上任教的讲师是最好的咨询对象。我联系了一位，她非常，其实说非常也不太公平，但她是一位CBT治疗师，一位合格的CBT治疗师。
And I guess kind of gives that more CBT lens. And then I also contacted my research supervisor at the time who, I guess, took more of a critical lens towards clinical psychology and some of those more community psychology values and then yeah and then we all got together and then yeah created the the proposal and then that got accepted and then yeah April April this year I was it was like a second thesis trying to finish it off and trying to finish off the illustrations and stuff amazing so we're recording this at the tail end of 2023 um but we're very much planning that this episode is going to come out when your book is available so tell us what it's called tell us where you're imagining it might be available for purchase tell us all of those good things
我想她提供了一种更偏向CBT的视角。然后我还联系了当时的研究导师，我想她对临床心理学采取了更批判的视角，以及一些更具社区心理学价值的观点。然后我们聚在一起，创建了提案，提案被接受了。然后，今年四月，这就像是第二篇论文，试图完成它，试图完成插图等等。太棒了。所以我们是在2023年底录制的，但我们非常希望这一集播出时你的书已经上市了。所以告诉我们书名，告诉我们你认为可以在哪里购买，告诉我们所有这些好消息。
so it's called an illustrated guide to clinical psychology and yeah it's by my myself Juliette Young and then Dr Catherine Butler Dr Rachel Pascal um and it's going to be available on Amazon I think it's already available for sort of pre-sale and yeah major bookshops um we're also doing a book launch, which I think may be on, I think it's the 27th, 28th in Bath. So if you're in Bath, but there'll be information about that on my Instagram page and on my Twitter page, closer to the time around that. Brilliant. How exciting, your very own book launch what an exciting book baby to be launching on the world yeah so your ideal client for that is an aspiring
所以书名是《临床心理学插图指南》，作者是我自己Juliette Young，还有Catherine Butler博士和Rachel Pascal博士。它将在亚马逊上架，我想现在已经可以预售了，还有各大书店。我们还要举办一个新书发布会，我想可能是在27号或28号，在巴斯。所以如果你在巴斯，我的Instagram页面和Twitter页面上会有关于那次活动的信息。太棒了。真令人兴奋，你自己的新书发布会，这是一个多么令人兴奋的“书宝宝”要推向世界啊。所以你的理想读者是那些有抱负的
psychologist is that the is that that's the ICA yeah yeah so uh aspiring psychologists um we also talked about it just being useful for newly qualified psychologists and also those who might be working alongside clinical psychologists and wanting to understand what it is as a profession, you know, to have find it useful to reference for another section someone else has written on, on, I don't know, cognitive analytic therapy. And just to remind myself what the key principles is very much an intro and summary. So there's, you know, a page or two per idea, per therapy modality, per approach. There's stuff around, yeah, the first chapters on kind of the history and some context. And there's stuff around um yeah the first chapters on kind of the history and some context and there's stuff around key skills so it's yeah it's a pick up flick and you know put down or you know or you might want to read it back to front but it's yeah sort of for anybody that it might
心理学家，是吗？是的，所以是那些有抱负的心理学家。我们也谈到它对刚获得资格的心理学家很有用，也对那些可能与临床心理学家一起工作，并想了解这个职业的人很有用。你知道，如果能作为参考资料，比如别人写的关于认知分析疗法的部分，会很有用。提醒自己关键原则是什么。这非常像是一本入门书和总结。所以，每个想法、每种治疗方式、每种方法都有两页左右的内容。第一章是关于历史和一些背景，还有关于关键技能的内容。所以这是一本可以随手翻阅的书，或者你也可以从后往前读，但它适合任何觉得它有用的人。
be useful to really it sounds brilliant have you designed your cover as well i'm imagining it's brilliantly illustrated yes so yeah the cover is the cover was I gave the illustrations it's been put together by a graphic designer actually because that's yeah that's not one of my strengths or at least something I've not tried before is the kind of the composing things in a graphic design way so and have you have you seen it yet have you held it in your hands as yet? Not a physical copy. We had the final proof, just PDF sent through the other day, which is, yeah, sort of bizarre to see, you know, the ISB numbers or the, you know,
听起来太棒了。你设计了封面吗？我猜它一定有精美的插图。是的，封面是我提供的插图，实际上是由一位平面设计师排版的，因为那不是我的强项，或者至少是我以前没有尝试过的事情，即以平面设计的方式构图。你看到了吗？你拿到实物了吗？还没有拿到实体书。我们前几天收到了最终校样，只是PDF文件，看到ISBN号码或者其他信息，感觉很奇妙。
and we've had some endorsers who have read it and given some comments on it. And it's, yeah, it feels, yeah, it's just really exciting. Like I did, I remember sitting down with um one of the other trainees a year into training and sort of talking about wanting to take it a bit easy on training and say oh it's not like we're going to write a book or anything and then here I am you know four years later with my book coming out in a few months it just yeah I love that and um if people want to learn more about you or follow you on socials, where should they head, Juliet? So Instagram's probably the best place. So I'm creative.clinical.psychologist.
我们有一些推荐人读过它并给出了一些评论。这感觉真的很令人兴奋。我记得在培训一年后，我和另一位实习生坐在一起，谈论想在培训中轻松一点，说我们又不是要写书什么的。然后四年后的今天，我的书几个月后就要出版了。我喜欢这样。如果人们想了解更多关于你的信息或在社交媒体上关注你，他们应该去哪里，Juliet？Instagram可能是最好的地方。我的账号是creative.clinical.psychologist。
I've recently set up an Instagram for my Dr. Juliet Young. Brilliant. Thank you. I'll make sure there's details in the show notes for how people can follow you there will also be details in the show notes of how you can buy juliet's book as well which is available now as we are looking at future march 2024 so thank you so much for your time wishing you the absolute best of luck with your first book baby I hope it flies really well for you and really makes a difference and helps people understand what it is that we do and perhaps feel a bit more contained
我最近为我的Dr. Juliet Young账号建立了一个Instagram。太棒了。谢谢。我会确保在节目说明中提供人们如何关注你的详细信息。节目说明中也会有关于如何购买Juliet的书的详细信息，这本书现在已经可以购买了，因为我们现在展望的是2024年3月。非常感谢你的时间，祝你的第一本“书宝宝”好运。我希望它能大卖，真正发挥作用，帮助人们理解我们所做的工作，并或许能让他们感到更被包容
and understood by those around us as well. Yeah, yeah, I hope so. And you've given us lots of lovely advice to reduce burnout along the way in clinical psychology as well. So thank you for sharing that with us. And thank you for sharing your time with us too. thank you for having me on i've really enjoyed talking to you today marianne oh thank you likewise now how incredible please do go and follow juliet over on
和被周围的人理解。是的，我希望如此。你还为我们提供了许多减少临床心理学职业倦怠的宝贵建议。谢谢你与我们分享这些。也谢谢你抽出时间与我们交流。谢谢你邀请我，我今天和你谈得很开心，Marianne。哦，谢谢，同样。现在，太不可思议了，请一定要去关注Juliet的
instagram creative clinical psychologist and her book is available now so check out the details in the show notes or if you look on my social, you'll be able to see links to the book as well. Hope you found that interesting. I love the way that psychology allows us to blend our skills, our interests and our passions into our clinical work. I'd love to know what you think to this episode.
Instagram账号creative clinical psychologist，她的书现在已经上市了，所以请查看节目说明中的详细信息，或者如果你查看我的社交媒体，也能看到这本书的链接。希望你觉得这很有趣。我喜欢心理学让我们将技能、兴趣和热情融入临床工作的方式。我很想知道你对这一集的看法。
Come and let me know over in the free Facebook group, the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. Please do also subscribe and like if you're watching on YouTube. And why not consider checking out the Aspiring Psychologist membership, as well as my own books, the Aspiring Psychologist Collective and The Clinical Psychologist Collective book. Thank you so much for being part of my world. And I will look forward to catching up with you for the next episode of the podcast, which will be available from 6am on Monday. Take care. then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified
来免费的Facebook群组“Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent”告诉我吧。如果你在YouTube上观看，请务必订阅并点赞。为什么不考虑看看“Aspiring Psychologist”会员资格，以及我自己的书《Aspiring Psychologist Collective》和《The Clinical Psychologist Collective》呢？非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。我期待在下一集播客中与你相见，该集将于周一早上6点发布。保重。让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。
it's the aspiring psychologist with dr marianne my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything
这是Dr. Marianne的《Aspiring Psychologist》。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《The Clinical Psychologist Collective》这本书，我发现关于所有不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，成为临床心理学家没有完美的路径，这让我充满了信心，觉得我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切
will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就放不下这本书了。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。